c'est l'illustration de l'engagement de
l'état pour la restauration du
patrimoine des investissements du plan
france relance engagés dans deux projets
l'aménagement autour du moulin de saint
cyr l'école après sa destruction et la
rénovation de l'école nationale de
l'architecturé versailles l'objet du
double déplacement du préfet de région
d'île de france marc guillaume ce qui
est comme en revanche aux deux sites
c'est l'impact du plan de relance à
arriver à mobiliser d'un côté avec le
conseil régional le conseil
départemental de l'intercommunalité 9
millions d'euros pour faire ses travaux
sur cet ancien moulin ancienne minoterie
est ici dégagé près de 30 millions
d'euros pour arriver à moderniser
l'école d'architecturé la démolition du
moulin de saint cyr l'école va permettre
la construction d'un parking
un aménagement à proximité de l'allée
royale de villepreux le nom d'un arrêt
sur la future ligne 13 du tramway entre
saint germain en laye et saint cyr
l'école
tout cela alors que les épreuves
équestres des jeux olympiques de paris
en 2024 se tiendront ici les jeux seront
et nous on se retrouve devant la grille
a fait l'aller qui est derrière nous
n'allez qui prolongeait le tapis vert et
le grand canal du parc du château de
versailles sur 4 kilomètres à travers la
plaine de versailles
là il s'agit d'en replanter 800 mètres
entre la sortie du parc et l'autoroute
a12
on a déjà replanté 140 ormes on va
encore en planter 300 le l'automne
prochain et le reste sera planté l'année
suivante
du côté de l'école nationale supérieure
de l'architecturé en face du château de
versailles la toiture et les huisseries
vont faire peau neuve
trois tranches de travaux menés en même
temps jusqu'en 2022 les huisseries sont
en très mauvais état ils n'ont pas été
reprises depuis très très longtemps est
né il ya beaucoup de fuites de fuites
dans les toitures beaucoup de chez nos
bouchers du aura également dans ce
projet une partie de rénovation
énergétique qui nous permettra de faire
des économies très substantiel en
complément de cette restauration à
l'école recherchent des mécènes privés
pour restaurer la façade de
l'établissement